I get a deep sense of hope when I look
at this
brick it's going to spend the next 50
years of its life cutting CO2 and Bricks
Like It are going to cut
15% of world
CO2 so let's talk about that but first
we have to talk about
fire fire warms us Heats our homes Cooks
our food we also use fire to make almost
everything industrial production making
stuff uses more fossil fuel than any
other part of the world economy we burn
coal oil and gas to make steel caline
cement cook baby food make glass make
fabric everything we don't notice it in
our daily lives but industrial energy
use is thear largest part of the total
World economy and Industrial heat is a
quarter of world fossil fuel use and
World carbon
emissions let me say that again
industrial heat is a quarter of world's
carbon pollution we need the stuff we
make we need to decarbonize our industry
not
de-industrialized how if we had a new
kind of fire we could decarbonize today
and avoid the time and and costs
associated with replacing our factories
that run on heat if we had clean
heat we could have the stuff that we use
and we could have a giant drop in World
emissions but for decades we've dreamed
of burning hydrogen or capturing carbon
to get clean heat but costs and
challenges continue to delay their
deployment the good news news is today
there is a faster cheaper way of doing
it
electrification analysts now say that
electrified industrial heat is the next
trillion dollar market I agree they're
right because the ongoing cost dropping
in wind and solar power costs now are
dropping to the point that wind and
solar cost less than the fuels our
factories burn so we have the economic
conditions to drive to scale we also
have the capacity to build at scale
today we have everything we need to
build wind and solar at scale to repower
Industrial
heat yes it's terawatts it's five times
more wind and solar than is in the world
today but there is a solution we have
everything we need except
continuity right the wind blows and The
Sun Shines only some of the time heavy
industry needs heat all the
time so we need to store energy some of
the time so we can have clean heat all
the time how most ways of storing
electricity are too expensive or
inefficient to use for industrial
heat but what if we just stored
heat storing electricity as heat can be
simple and really low cost teams around
the world are now trying to build
industrial heat batteries that store
energy this way using new materials like
liquid salts liquid metals and solid
carbon and some of these are going to
work they'll take time time to learn if
they're safe time to learn how long they
last uh time to learn how to make a lot
of something
new my colleagues at Ronda found a way
to save time to go Faster by using old
materials that the world already makes
in
volume what were they here's a hint one
of them was brick uh the other was iron
wire why
Brick 200 years ago the steel industry
introduced a coal saving technology they
started Building blast stoves that store
Heat at thousands of degrees in
thousands of tons of brick brick is
basically made from dirt and dirt is
available at
scale when it's red hot a brick stores
as much energy as a lithium ion battery
per pound costs 10 times less lasts 10
times
longer half a million tons of brick are
storing Heat at steel mills around the
world right now iron wire a 100 years
ago a new alloy for uh heating elements
from toasters to Industrial furnaces was
invented that is made only of iron and a
little chromium and aluminum today that
heating element is on your kitchen
counter and in industrial furnaces and
kill around the world combining brick
and wire could be really cost effective
we would know how to make a lot of it
right away but there are some challenges
if you overheat a brick in on one side
if you don't heat it evenly it can crack
if you overheat just one spot on a wire
the wire May Fail we have the we finally
found the way to do it the way to
combine these was to heat brick the way
your toaster Heats bread the way the sun
heats the Earth with radiant heat it
only took us 74 design revisions to find
the solution and hundreds of simulations
but the key Insight heating brick with
radiation we built a 3D Checker Board of
brick and open Chambers the chambers let
radiant heat spread the heat evenly so
electricity can heat thousands of tons
of brick to thousands of degrees safely
and
evenly once you've done that now you
have stored energy and delivering clean
heat is really simple push air into the
brick stack super heated air comes out
that powers your Kil or your furnace or
Heats a boiler to make Steam for your
chemical plant or your food production
facility Presto you have a heat battery
an industrial boiler that runs all day
all night all year on the wind or the
Sun a cement Kiln that burns no fuel a
chocolate factory with zero scope one
and scope two emissions simple lowc cost
and
efficient I brought this brick for
showand tell it's going to spend the
next 50 years of its life in a heat
battery running at thousands of degrees
over a thousand C you know when it's at
temperature it stores more energy than a
Tesla Model X uh we put about 3,000 of
those in a box to make one heat battery
we didn't have spares this is a this is
actually going into a unit
um we are now at this very interesting
point technology like this is simple
it's boring it can go to scale fast if
you want to go to scale fast it's good
to be boring to use these simple
processes there is a valy of death that
everyone talks about about new
technologies between new technologies
where High Capital cost can absorb
uncertainty and low Capital cost huge
infrastructure needs certain certainty
new and boring is a really strange
combination but it's an excellent recipe
for going fast leading climate
investment funds industrial producers
agreed that our kind of boring is a good
idea and have helped us build a great
team to build big and go fast today
Rondo is supplying heat for lowc carbon
fuel production and developing projects
around the world that
will produce food chemicals metal
and cement we are producing bricks at
gwatt scale and uh growing that
production over the next few years 100
fold so we're at the beginning of a
rapid ramp tackling our climate crisis
needs our will but it also needs tools
to build big new energy infrastructure
fast this is one of those tools it's a 6
gigaton tool analysts say the the fully
decarbonized world needs twice as much
heat battery storage as grid battery
storage heat batteries powered by the
wind and sun will lower not raise the
cost of making the things we need in the
decarbonized world this new kind of fire
will power a safer more prosperous more
just world for our children and their
children our challenge Rondo's great
opportunity is to build at scale to
repower the world's
industry and save 15% of world CO2
emissions and with your help we can get
that done in 15 years that's why I have
hope and I hope you do
too thank
you